Or would you pretend you weren't alone?
So, you wake up one day and find that
you're the only person left in the world.
Kind of cool, right?
No obligations,
no rules,
no limits.
Go for the exotic fruits first.
If your mangos and bananas
are imported from overseas,
chances are they'll be hard to come by.
So eat them while you can,
and enjoy every last bite.
You might think that with no one stopping you,
you could go anywhere.
But not so fast!
All those abandoned cars, boats,
and planes you see lying around
will be useless in about 2 years
when their fuel goes stale.
Guess you'll be sticking around.
But for how long?
If water,
food
and shelter
are your basic needs,
shelter would be the easiest to come by.
You'd literally have a world
of homes to choose from!
But be careful where you settle down.
Cities would become dangerous,
since without proper maintenance,
they'd start to fall apart pretty quickly.
Nature's elements: rain, frost, and heat,
would take their toll.
Rot and mold would become widespread,
and vegetation would crack through
concrete and break through glass.
But even if you were to fight back
against nature's reclamation of the land,
all it takes is one bolt of lightning
to start a city-wide fire.
And you can't call the fire department.
So run for the hills!
But even the country isn't all that safe.
First of all, there are predators
you'd need to defend against.
Wild dogs, feral cats...
bears...
But you'd only have to worry about them
as long as you could still breathe.
There are more than
400 nuclear power plants in the world.
And once their automated safety systems
began to fail without human supervision,
there would be meltdowns
across the planet,
rendering many regions
simply uninhabitable.
In terms of food,
the city would be your best bet.
Supermarkets have enough canned and
frozen food to last you for decades!
Whereas in the country,
crops and livestock would start to dwindle
without proper care or
protection from predators.
But if natural is more your style,
you'd have to go back to the old ways
of hunting with a spear or a bow,
since ammunition would be
limited and harder to come by.
Maybe you could grow your
own little vegetable garden,
but that would cut into your water resources.
Without other humans,
you'd be without electricity.
Water pumping stations and
treatment works would shut down,
and the fresh water kept in reservoirs
would go stale quite quickly.
You could rely on bottled water,
and you'd probably have
thousands of litres to go through,
but eventually, you'd have to
learn how to purify your own.
You'd have to teach yourself a lot of things,
but lucky for you, you've got
a lot of time on your hands,
and millions of books out there with
all the information you'd need
to survive effectively on your own.
So, while it might be hard at first,
you could technically survive
as the last human on Earth.
But would you really want to?
Humans evolved together as
social creatures in order to survive.
We joined forces against
hunger and harsh weather;
and built families and communities
to share stories, empathize,
and keep each other happy and healthy.
Human contact has been scientifically
proven to build trust and reduce stress.
So, while it's apt to cramp your style,
be glad it's a small world,
we need each other more than you think.